everything and more the Hollywood
Multiverse making all kinds of Oscar
history welcome everybody to
Entertainment Tonight You Know E.T is in
the middle of all the star-studded
madness but we begin with the question I
think that was on everyone's mind fair
to say how would the show address the
Oscar slap one year later the answer oh
just let Jimmy Kimmel do all the Dirty
Work
[Music]
during the show you will be awarded the
Oscar for best actor
and permitted to give a 19 minute long
speech and if any of you get mad at a
joke and decide you want to come up here
and get jiggy with it
you're gonna have to get through the
heavyweight champ Adonis Creed before
you get to me you were gonna
have for you get to me
with the Academy's new crisis team in
place three-time host Jimmy Kimmel
roasted Will Smith six times during the
show without saying his name once our
next category is documentary feature
which as you may recall is where we had
that little Skirmish last year hopefully
this time it goes off without a hitch or
at least without hitch Wanda what you
think of Jimmy tonight oh Jimmy you did
great that's right
tell me about it remember Wanda Sykes
co-hosted last year's show the slap got
will banned from Academy events for the
next decade so where was he on Sunday he
was spotted out and about in La just
around the time the nominees started to
arrive since will couldn't attend Oscar
winner Halle Berry stepped in to present
alongside last year's best actress
winner Jessica Chastain the ladies met
for the first time in front of et's
cameras
[Music]
what about the moment of Michelle having
a chance to win and the connection
between the two of you if she does I get
to give her that
watch for it listen Michelle Yo's
history making win was everything
everywhere all at once Michelle Young
[Applause]
what does it mean to be the first Asian
performer to win best actress at the
Oscars just hope that I'm not the last
just the beginning there were so many
people that I forgot to thank
well not her 84 year old Mama Janet who
was in tears watching from Malaysia
I love you guys my mother has always
instilled in me confidence the recent
thing that she asked me to do is don't
wear pants to the Oscar
my mother and my father were both
nominated for Oscars in different
categories
[Music]
obviously they're on my mind very much
so on my mind
Jamie Lee had her husband of 38 years
director Christopher Guest cheering her
on but before the show where's your date
tonight did you
protein bar in his
seat Angela Bassett was clearly
heartbroken when her name wasn't called
she was the other front-runner in the
category her biggest cheerleaders up to
this point twins Bronwyn matching in
purple and Sun Slater I think it's long
overdue and I really want to see her be
honored the way that I know she should
be now that we're here at the moment
finally it's like oh you can't exhale
yes we've been Waiting to Exhale for 29
years hey auntie we love you I love that
shout out for Angela
Angela got lots of love during and after
the show she quickly changed and hugged
it out with Michelle yo but Michelle's
co-star slash fellow first time winner
kiwi Kwan was the after party King how
does it feel thank you
clutching his Oscar posing on top of the
bar and embracing Anna to armis the best
supporting actor winner also got Terry
backstage with Jamie Lee this after
giving us several 80s mini-movie
reunions from hugging Indiana Jones
two my Goonies brother for life Jeff
Cohen
I have the key to one-eyed Willie I'm so
proud of you yep that's Jeff AKA chunk
who is now an entertainment lawyer he
helped key land his oscar-winning role
and Jeff and their former co-stars were
cheering him on because Goonies Never
Say Die Goonies Never Say Die
everything everywhere all at once became
the first movie in over 30 years to
sweep best picture director all of its
acting categories in just three hours
after Kimmel made this crack two actors
from Encino Man are nominated for Oscars
Brendan fazer
coaster and Encino Man it's a nice
reunion like I said when I first saw him
we're still here man we're still here it
couldn't be done
without my son's Holden and Leland and
Griffin and my best first mate Genie are
you so proud of your dad tonight oh yeah
it feels great the best actors
Renaissance is in full effect but at
home he's just dad with dad jokes what's
his worst
[Music]
the star Austin Butler who clutched
Angela Bassett for good luck and kept
the late Lisa Marie Presley in his heart
are you carrying a little bit of her
with you tonight you're carrying a lot
of her with me tonight Austin also had a
plus one with him best friend turned
agent of 14 years James Farrell we met
when I was 17. we grew up together I got
to see this journey that he went on it
was pretty special there's more Oscar
plus ones Brianna how you doing or in
riri's case plus two
the Oscar nominee was literally lifted
up during her performance as her man
ASAP Rocky cheered her on Backstage this
sweet moment as the 34 year old cradled
Rihanna's baby bump also stunning that's
a good date night how about that Idris
Elba and his wife Sabrina who dazzled in
green dude look at his lips listen you
supposed to lick your lips when you look
at your wife I did that's what he's
doing now listen you were saying
somebody needs to give me a part in a
black Panther movie I'm ready if I'm
invited into the wakanda series I would
love to be an old uncle that they forgot
and our nominee for best assist by a
husband Keith Urban who we spied fixing
his wife Nicole's hair just before they
post for pictures Zoe Saldana walked the
carpet with her hubby Marco perigo but a
lot of nominees made it more of a family
affair best actor nominee Paul meskel
and Gucci beamed with his mother at his
side the night was a bit Bittersweet on
the same day the 27 year old was
nominated his mom cut her hair to prep
for chemo treatment Paul was up against
Colin Farrell who brought his
13-year-old son that's magic today and
to have this film and have this fell
upon his side and young Henry's here The
Dashing Duo posed together in matching
black tuxits also twinning Salma Hayek
and her 15 year old daughter Valentina
the two joined presenter Pedro Pascal on
the carpet with his plus one his sister
Javier Obama Saida fans went wild for
Pedro who hit the carpet just as HBO was
airing the finale for his hit Thriller
The Last of Us you want to learn how to
play guitar as for the sweetest Oscar
PDA that goes to Miles Teller and his
wife Kelly Sperry they radiated old
Hollywood glamor as miles snuggled up
behind and planted a kiss
miles was there representing the crew of
top gun Maverick and after Lady Gaga
initially said she would not attend due
to her production schedule on the Joker
Sequel and ET Source says the best song
nominee quote changed her mind and just
in time to help this photographer's red
carpet crash landing
[Music]
we all need a hero sometimes
on stage Gaga went from a vixen in
Versace to wearing a t-shirt ripped
jeans and barely any makeup for this
strip down performance of hold my hands
[Music]
the performance paid tribute to the late
director of Top Gun Tony Scott Tom
Cruise meanwhile held true to his word
on skipping the ceremony he's in the UK
filming Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part two I was shooting with
Tom last night I am in town for 20 hours
flying back to London and then we're
going to the Arctic Circle to continue
shooting
is up doing TC things that make tctc
working well other people are playing
yeah listen you know for us to just be
here is absolutely amazing and we got a
huge
tell about another Blockbuster from
Tom's Top Gun producing partner Jerry
Bruckheimer right then what can you tell
us about Pirates and will we see Johnny
down I'm just going to ask you straight
out we're all working on them I would
love to have him in the movie that's all
I can tell you nice do I but Pirates
isn't the only movie news we got from
the stars I read the news that you were
gonna play Dennis Rodman in the biopic
48 hours in Vegas yeah I'm gonna do it I
want to get with them but I'm coming for
you let's have a chat uh humbly do you
have
I can pull
and just down the street at the Elton
John party our Cassie delore got more
details on upcoming projects what about
an update on girls trip too they are
working on a new script things are
coming together is there a girls group
chat oh yeah oh there's girls group chat
hey can you tell me anything about sex
in the city with John Corbett does he
tell you anything he got in really good
shape so I have a feeling there's a
nudity in that John's vegan now so he's
like he looks good
[Music]
foreign